okay so today it's my pleasure to
introduce our speaker
Peter Godfrey Smith who is the next
lecture in the series on philosophy
individuality and the humanities peter
is currently a distinguished professor
of philosophy at the Graduate Center at
the City University of New York he grew
up in Sydney Australia and did his
undergraduate degree at the University
of Sydney and his PhD at the University
of California San Diego he taught at
Stanford at Australian National
University and at Harvard
before coming to City University
Graduate Center in 2011 Peter's main
interests are in philosophy biology and
philosophy of mind he is also interested
in American pragmatism generally in the
philosophy of science and various parts
of metaphysics and epistemology recently
he's been very interested in both the
philosophy of communication and
individuality which he'll I think touch
upon both of those today peter has
written four books including complexity
in the function of mind in nature
theory and reality and introduction to
the philosophy of science
Darwinian populations and natural
selection which won the 2010 Lockett OSH
award and recently just released from
Princeton a philosophy of biology a
review book so thank you very much
welcome Peter
thanks very much this has already been a
very intense visit and I've only been
here for a couple of hours and haven't
yet given a talk so we'll see what
happens next okay so the living world
appears to us normally as a collection
of individual organisms and this
individual based view of life probably
runs quite deep in our folk biological
habits of thinking about the world and
indeed if we if we think back and
imagine the scene confronted in
prehistory by sort of caveman ancestors
I think that organisms must have been
some of the most conspicuously bounded
and encounter Ballabh jects around along
I guess with stars and that would have
been especially true before people began
making artifacts so it's not surprising
I think that when Aristotle in his work
the categories wanted some examples of
what he called primary substances the
most basic kinds of things that exist
the examples he gave were individual
horses and individual men from at least
the late 18th century onwards there's
been a keen interest in puzzle cases
cases where the individuality of a
living thing is unclear or as Darwin
described one marine example where
individuality is not yet completed
recent work in biology and in philosophy
of biology now contains a large
literature on what sort of thing a
biological individual is how individuals
are different kinds arise and how to
think about intermediate and enigmatic
cases a great deal of this literature
came out of a pioneering work by the
Yale biologist Leo buss a book called
the evolution of individuality which
came out just as I was entering graduate
school and which inspired me along with
many others most of the recent
discussion has been concerned in
retrospect I think we can see it was
concerned with what collects what might
collect the part
that is the spatial part of a system
into a single living individual so
people discuss things like bee colonies
symbiotic associations such as lichen
things like that but individuals of the
familiar kind are also unified in time
so you are made up both of spacial parts
such as your arms and your legs and also
made up of stages or temporal parts you
yesterday you today so individuals like
Aristotle's man and horse persist
through time as well as extending
through space now one term in philosophy
that's used for an object that persists
over time despite changing along the way
is the term continuant continued ant
continuent familiar living organisms
seem to be reproducing continuance
they're things that come into being
persist for a while may reproduce and
eventually die while they're alive they
grow and developed they grow and develop
and when they reproduce they make more
things of the same kind in some rough
sense as themselves so that's the
intuitive picture and this talk is going
to be about some questions concerning
individuality in biology that
specifically involved time and that
specifically put some pressure on this
idea of living thing as a reproducing
continuant now here's one reason why the
topic is important and this is going to
guide various things that I say
evolution by natural selection
Darwin's process is a very important
biological idea a central piece of
theory in biology standard summaries of
evolution by natural selection say it's
something that occurs when three things
are present variation in a population
differences in how much organisms
reproduce in that population and
heredity or heritability passing on
traits when organisms reproduce by this
means favorable mutations chance
variants that happen to be useful that
arise cannot just survive
but also spread can become prevalent and
provide the basis for new rounds of
chains now here on the slide is a
summary a more officially worded summary
of how evolution by natural selection
works and how it involves these three
ingredients I won't read it out but I
leave it up there for a while so you can
see how things look in detail so that's
from Richard Lewontin a geneticist
writing in the 80s if we ask what sort
of picture of organisms a summary like
that embodies I think it embodies
something that's quite familiar and
close to a folk biological or intuitive
or pre theoretic view of what organisms
are so the summary has it that organisms
are things that come in to exist they're
born they reproduce making more things
at the same kind and with the favored
traits being passed on in reproduction
because of the operation of heritability
all this is quite intuitive and the
basic ideas here as Lou Anton emphasizes
in this passage in the material
surrounding it are of course ideas from
Darwin and Darwin was thinking
especially about animals like pigeons
and farm animals though also barnacles
he was thinking about mostly thinking
about organisms that have a rather
intuitive kind of individuality what
I'll do in this paper is put some
pressure on this picture of organisms
and reproduction as it relates to
standard ways like this of thinking
about evolution by natural selection and
I want to emphasize that the pressure is
not only being put on these intuitive
folk biological views but also on
standard ways of summarizing how
evolution works so it's often been said
or at least sometimes been said that
familiar descriptions of evolution have
been guided by a kind of vertebrates
centric view of life ignoring all the
other kinds of organisms that exist or
trying to squash them into a vertebrate
mold and I think that's true and
especially true in the context that I'll
be talking about today so here is what
I'll be talking about in familiar verda
cases animals like ourselves it's pretty
clear where one organism begins and ends
both in space and also in time and
reproduction is something that's fairly
easy to see so organisms from time to
time make more things like themselves so
reproduction might be said intuitively
and also in a kind of basic biology to
involve two things recurrence and
production you get new things that are
similar to things that were around
before so forms recur more horses for
Aristotle more pigeons for Darwin and
these new things come from or are
produced by earlier horses and pigeons
parents of the new ones
horses recur as time passes because
they're being made by other horses now
that makes sense and it's embedded in a
familiar summary like the Lu anthem
summary however that's not always how
things work it's quite common for things
to be different once we move from
familiar animals like ourselves to other
kinds of living things and that will be
the topic of the talk so what I'll do in
the talk is introduce the problem in
some detail and then suggest a solution
where the solution will take the form of
a somewhat new framework in which the
familiar idea of reproduction taken for
granted in summaries like this is
treated as a special case of something
that's broader and it involves other
kinds of cases as well okay before
introducing the problem of trying to
focus our thinking even more with the
aid of a diagram a diagram that
emphasizes the idea that biology
recognizes individuals at different
scales in space and time the diagram is
due to willie Hennig from his book
phylogenetic systematics
so in Hennings diagram circles represent
individuals present at three different
spatial and temporal scales and time
goes up the page so species are the
largest circles within species are
smaller circles for individual organisms
linked to each other by sexual
reproduction and below that level on the
lower right an individual organism is
broken down by Hennig into inter stages
which Hannah called some afferents
Hennig love decline terminology some of
which is caught on and some of which has
not now Henning who is an entomologist
working on insects was very attentive to
the importance of changes in form within
the lifetime of an individual a juvenile
can look entirely different from an
adult now in some cases what we might
think of these stage as these stages
these sim afferents and Hennings picture
are only artificially bounded as change
is more or less continuous that's true
in things like us in other cases there's
a sharper and more non-arbitrary divided
between some stages some kind of
metamorphosis step in the lifetime of
the individual now I take it that a kind
of folk biology and intuitive non theory
based biology is not particularly
troubled by the fact of change within a
lifetime a caterpillar changes to a
butterfly Aristotle's horse and human
also changed a great deal although more
continuously than the caterpillar now a
person a philosopher probably might
insist that a butterfly is in a certain
sense a new object a different
individual from the caterpillar when the
divide between stages is very sharp and
the forms are very different but if
somebody else disagrees and says no it's
the same individual though it has
changed some of its properties it
doesn't seem to be a great deal to argue
about there and certainly the view that
the caterpillar and the butterfly are
stages of a single extended individual
is certainly in available position it's
not something that involves some kind of
contradiction so change per se is not a
problem in particular not a problem for
the idea that the world the living world
is made up of reproducing individuals
which persist reproducing continuance so
the idea which is important to a luetin
type summary of evolution
that can be expressed informally by
saying like makes like you know horses
make horses and particular kinds of
horses tend to make similar kinds of
horses I feel like that is entirely
compatible with the fact that the first
stage of a new organism the baby or the
larvae is not very much like its parents
certainly in many cases so the idea of
reproduction and heredity and
individuality is a feature of living
world is not troubled by that so long as
the newborn animal grows up into
something that does look like its
parents in in relevant ways
metamorphosis is a more notable
phenomenon of this kind but still not
that big a deal okay so so far no
pressure so far folk biology aristotle
darwin lu anton are all sort of more or
less on the same page about what sorts
of things living individuals are but now
we'll start to talk about problem cases
and in particular the phenomena i'll be
talking about or using to motivate the
main ideas of this talk involve a
particular kind of life cycle seen in
many organisms in which there's what's
called an alternation of generations and
these are cases which interfere with
familiar habits of thought about
biological organisms in the following
way rather than a is making mores horses
making more horses and so on as make
bees which in turn make a's so you get
back to a but only through a Waystation
something physically quite different
alternation of generations is very
common it's seen in plants fungi single
celled animals of various kinds and some
animals sometimes there's a compression
of one of the generations alternating so
you barely notice it in other cases
there's more symmetry and alternation of
generations is often part of a haploid
diploid cycle that is as the alternation
goes on the genomes of organisms double
and half in size ordinary fur
of the kind that are all around us are a
dramatic case the sporophyte the
familiar fern shaped plant is diploid
has two sets of chromosomes that's the
thing you might buy from the nursery it
produces spores when it reproduces or
when it well it produces spores we'll
talk about shortly whether that's
reproduction it's support it produces
spores by means of meiosis where the
spores have one set of chromosomes each
spore can grow up into a haploid plant
into a plant with that genetic profile
where the plant is called a gametophyte
these are visible plants smaller than
two sporophytes they do have
photosynthetic capacity they have in a
sense a life of their own
those gametophyte produce sex cells
which are also haploid single set of
chromosomes and the male sex cells or
gametes swim to the female gametes on
the gametophyte and fuse with them a new
sporophyte grows up there attached to
the gametophyte so in some sporophyte
s-- produce gametophyte s' a sexually
and comida fights produce sporophytes
sexually so that's the that's the basic
firm lifecycle is that a case of
metamorphosis which we encountered a
moment ago with butterflies and
caterpillars perhaps you might say that
the sporophyte - gametophyte step the
one on the top arrow there is a case of
metamorphosis no I think you can't
really say that because each sporophyte
can make many gametophyte each a can
make many bees just as each bee can make
many many aids so in a case like this if
only one bee can come from each a then a
step could be seen as metamorphosis one
butterfly from each caterpillar here
though at both stages does
multiplication so to think about the
ferns I think rather than just saying
it's something like metamorphosis we
should think about what it would look
like if humans did something like this
so imagine that humans were all the same
sex and we all produce two kind of sperm
like stuff each cell of which could grow
up by cell division into something that
looked like a giraffe where the giraffe
then lived its life and eventually had
sex with another giraffe and when the
pregnant giraffe gave birth it gave
birth to a human so that's what it would
look like if humans had an alternation
of generations it's much stranger than
metamorphosis okay so what are the
individuals in a case like this and you
might find it useful to think about the
giraffe human alternation when asking
this question well one way of thinking
about organisms or individuals in
biology is just to ignore reproduction
and think about the metabolic units the
things that have a kind of metabolic
life or things that take in energy keep
themselves going and so on and then we
could just say simply that both the
sporophyte and the gametophyte are
individuals they have their own life
because their metabolic units in their
own right the problem arises
instead around the idea that an organism
is both is a living and a reproducing
thing a reproducing continuant to use
the term I used earlier something that
persists and makes more things of the
same kind so let's now look more closely
at cases like the fern so a's produced
bees bees produce a's who if anyone
reproduces now you might say well the
new a is made indirectly by the old a
but of course the new a is been made
directly by a B and there are Fitness
like properties on both sides so a
sporophyte can either be good or bad at
making gametophyte and a gametophyte can
either be good or bad at making
sporophytes if you think of Fitness is
important here you can ask both
questions if we want to think about a
case like this or there's a schematic
diagram of the fern case so you've got
sporophyte switch diploid two sets of
chromosomes that give rise a sexually to
the gametophyte switch grow up like the
giraffe human
alternation case they then sexually
reproduce and give rise to a new
generation of sporophytes okay if you
want to think about a case like this
while making as few changes to our
normal ways of talking as possible and
by saying well something in this system
it's a reproducing object then I think
there are five ways of doing it firstly
you might you might make one of the two
processes either the HOA step or the b2b
step the thing you call reproduction and
you treat the other step as part of
they're just part of the machinery part
of the process so and you make that
distinction based on some objective
distinction between the two secondly you
might say well you can just choose you
can either make the a to a step
reproduction or the B to B step but
that's a free choice reduction or sub
sumption you treat neither of them
neither a nor B neither sporophyte nor
gametophyte as a reproducing object you
find something lower level perhaps cells
or genes or higher level something
larger that reproduces without an
alternation fourth you might say well a
making B is reproduction even though the
word even though the the the the re part
of that sounds a bit odd
it is reproduction even though they're
so different lastly I think in some ways
the more interesting of the this first
round of options you might say there's a
kind of entanglement in two forms of
reproduction here and to Darwinian
process is tied together where the A's
make A's with bees as a way station and
bees make bees with A's as a way station
in the case of ferns
some people might initially choose
priority and say look the sporophyte
reproduced they're the real organisms
here and the gametophyte suggests a way
station the sporophyte is bigger and
longer lived
not so with mosses but that's how it is
with ferns
however the gametophyte sometimes
resists the idea that they are not
genuine reproduces they can break out
the cycle of alternation either partly
or oh holy so about 10% of thern species
have gametophyte that reproduce
vegetatively just on they're making more
gametophyte asexually in some cases the
comida fides shift between making more
of themselves and making sporophytes in
the new the next generation in other
cases they're given up on the
alternation completely so in the
Appalachian Mountains of the u.s. there
are at least four species of ferns that
have become gametophyte only so
sporophytes have not been seen for a
long time and there are also cases the
other way there are cases of sporophyte
breakout I think that many biologists
the working biologists at this point
might say okay it's time for some
reduction here genetic reproduction or
genetic replication has no alternation
and that's all we need to pay attention
to here both the sporophytes and the
gametophyte s-- might be just seen as
some of the varied Pro some of the
varied products of gene action this
person might say that parent offspring
relationships between these big things
are not particularly evolutionarily
important so it doesn't matter if we
can't work out where they are because
those big things are just clouds in the
sky dust storms in the desert to use two
phrases taken from Richard Dawkins who
would have defended a view of this who
would defend a view of this kind so you
might say that we should just reduce the
evolutionary description to the level of
competing genes and forget the larger
objects now this reductionist option is
a genuine possibility I'm not going to
argue directly against it and I can see
how for a practicing biologist it's the
natural way to proceed at this point
it's a way of getting a workable
description that avoids the complexity
and the oddity of these cases what I'll
do here is not argue against the
reductionist view but use these cases to
introduce and motivate a different way
of thinking about all these phenomena
and then at the very end I'll come back
and discuss how it relates to the
genetic
option and the difference between the
two approaches is essentially this the
the reductionist approach we just go
down to the level of genes as well that
is going down to the level of genes is a
reductionist attitude to the problem and
the approach that I'll present instead
is involves a strategy of abstraction
rather than reduction okay I listed four
five options there the other two options
I won't say much about their strange
heredity and entanglement both of them
have seen a little bit ad hoc perhaps as
responses for the problem when
considered individually but in some ways
the view I'll defend involves a
combination of those last two options
and more generally though I used to
think when I began thinking about these
cases I used to think that that was the
list and we just had to choose some one
of the things on this list to deal with
the cases now I think cases like this
motivator quite different move and I'll
now start talking about that that
different move and the different move
requires that we see ordinary Darwinian
processes involving reproduction as a
special case of something broader okay
so now I'll present now I'll present a
positive picture
let's step back from biological details
for a second and think very abstractly
not just about living things but about
everything about the world as a whole as
time passes present states of systems of
all kind give rise to later states of
those systems or strictly speaking you
might say the block that's the world and
a given at one time gives rise as a
whole to a block which is the whole
world at the next time step the whole
present is responsible for the whole
future that's the general case in some
systems of course change is organized in
a particular way where there's local
responsibilities at least partially
where some of the pieces of the present
block are responsible for particular
pieces of future blocks and biological
reproduction where parents give rise to
future individuals offspring is one
aspect of this let's get there though in
stages get to biological reproduction in
stages I'll begin with a very broad in
fact almost indefinitely broad concept
of just production where production is
seen whenever one object or one
arrangement of objects or one system at
a time gives rise to another object or
arrangement or state of a system at a
later time where each of these things
might be anything at all now it's not
assumed that the object can do this all
on its own with no other causes working
and they'll always be other clauses and
background conditions that are important
but I'm assuming that there are degrees
of responsibility here
so there's production of future states
of systems and objects by present or
past states of systems and objects
within that broad category some patterns
of production exhibit cycles with
recurrence of forms that were seen
earlier so a makes B B makes C C makes D
perhaps and eventually this sequence
gives rise to a new a now a cycle like
this might be very short where
makes a right away or it might be long a
makes B make C makes D then you get back
to a the amount of cycling can change so
the this the fern cases with gametophyte
breakout by cases where a larger cycle a
to b to a gets reduced to a smaller
cycle a to a now any form in a sequence
might be seen as the beginning of a
cycle and whether a cycle is present at
all will depend on the scale at which
the system is being viewed so there
might be recurrence at a microscopic
level without there being a return to
earlier forms at the macroscopic level
or vice versa for now on though I'll
assume we're dealing with a particular
family of cases the familiar cases in
which we have living things as our
objects and specifically living things
that are large enough to be
multicellular I won't be talking about
single celled organisms okay further
distinction can then be made divided in
cases of cyclical production so some
kinds of production involve cycles and
some don't
dividing further some kinds of cyclical
production involve multiplication and
some do not
so either it's the case that from one a
or a small number such as a pair you can
get many A's arising later or perhaps
you can't now if there's no cycle if you
just have a making be making C making D
and never returning you might say well
this distinction concerning
multiplication is still available you
could have multiple multiplicative
processes of production that are not
cyclical I'm not sure at least sometimes
and perhaps always in principle it'll be
unclear whether this multiplication or
not because of questions about how to
count the products of the late present
at the later stages so if a cycle is
present then it is clear whether you
have a multiplicative or a non
multiplicative system because either
more objects of the a type arise or they
don't
so the original a's give you a kind of
reference object with which to assess
whether or not there's multiplication as
goes on if there's no cycle you don't
really have a reference object in the
relevant sense another distinction some
change of production include a
bottleneck step and some do not
now this is one of this is the feature
of the version of the story here that's
specifically relevant I think to
organisms like us with many cells and
I'll say a bit eventually about how the
framework might be extended but
certainly in some systems the presence
or absence of a bottleneck is important
where a bottleneck is a dramatic
narrowing in the amount of structure
present so in the case of humans making
humans that's the reduction in the life
cycle to a single celled stage so you go
you have a lot of cells go down to one
and you grow up into a lot of cells
where there's a bottleneck at the one
celled stage now as in the case of
multiplication the question of whether
bottlenecks exists in a sequence seems
applicable in cases where there are no
cycles as well as cases where there are
cycles but perhaps those questions about
whether there's one verse as many or
more verses less that cause trouble
earlier also arise here in the case of
bottlenecks anyway I'm going to set that
aside here and for now on I'll only be
considering cases with cycles and
narrowings
within cycles that reduce multicellular
stages of organisms to single celled
stages that's hell do it today although
you could extend the framework I think
lastly last distinction there may or may
not be sex at any given stage in a chain
of production events where I understand
sex very broadly here as any fusion of
contributions from two productive
lineages now whether sex is present will
again depend on on the scale at which
the system is being viewed okay with
those concepts in hand we could say the
first thing we might say as well
biological reproduction
in the broadest possible sense is just
cyclical production in a living system
which includes some sort of event that
distinguishes the situation from a
situation of simple persistence with
change where sex bottlenecks and
multiplication might all be taken as
candidate things that are distinguished
a change from mere persistence of an
object from cases where you have the
production of new objects or
reproduction so that's the first thing
you might say about reproduction
however the cases of reproduction that
we are familiar with
the ones that guide Darwin and Lewin to
an Aristotle all have a particular
arrangement of these features so let's
now start to compare cases firstly and
I'll compare the cases using the same
format of diagram in each case let's
look at the familiar human life cycle in
this life cycle there's sex recurrence
so sex multiplication and a bottleneck
and they all take place once before
recurrence and all at roughly the same
place so humans whole human beings like
us make many gametes eggs and sperm
which can each fuse with a gamete of the
other sex to make a zygote which can
grow up into a new human being now on
the slide there so I use divergent
arrows to indicate multiplication
convergent arrows to indicate sex and
small circles to indicate the presence
of a bottleneck
now I mark the multiplication step here
the divergent arrows as the step where
gametes or sex cells eggs and sperm are
produced because this is the point at
which many future humans can have their
histories converge or coalesce now you
might wonder whether that's the right
way to think about the nature of the
multiplication step here but that's how
I'm going to do it
small circles indicating bottlenecks are
drawn at both the gamete and zygote
stages but I count this as a single
bottleneck a single narrowing because
you went down to one cell at a sink on a
single occasion and then you work your
way back out of it once the diagram is
of course not drawn as a cycle people
talk of a life cycle but I think it's
good to make explicit the fact that
recurrence is to a state that similar
rather than identical to what to what
was present before okay so there is the
familiar human life cycle drawn with a
particular set of conventions a case
like this is very naturally described in
terms of reproduction by a temporally
extended object a continuant a new human
is a thing that appears at conception
and continues to death with reproduction
along the way and reproduction makes
more of these things these reproducing
continuance so humans I think are clear
cases of reproducing continuance once
we've isolated the factors that make
this clear we can see that the
arrangement of those factors seen in
humans is just one of many ways that
those features can be arranged even when
all of them is present so let's now
return immediately to the ferns and draw
the fern lifecycle using the same
conventions I introduced for the human
case so now there are two multiplication
steps before recurrence so before you
get where you started you have two
events with the diverging arrows to
indicate multiplication both of which
involve a bottleneck one of which
involves sex so rather than before
recurrence one bottleneck sex and one
multiplicative event in the ferns before
recurrence you have two multiplicative
events both with bottlenecks and with
sex at one of those steps so all of the
things that are seen in humans are
present but they're not seen in the same
arrangement as they are in a human life
cycle now for me at least the feature
that causes the most disruption for
standard ways of thinking about
individuality and reproduction is the
second multiplication step the thing I
emphasize when I did my human and
giraffe thought experiment without that
step if there was just one
multiplication step you could see a fern
as a single individual that stayed alive
and persisted through lots of change in
its form throughout its life so if in
particular each sporophyte that's the
thing on the far left could only give
rise to a single gametophyte in
principle then you could see that as a
metamorphosis step of an unusually
dramatic kind and then you could say
that just as a human is an extended
thing that makes more humans although
humans change in their lives a
sporophyte and gametophyte combination
that whole extended object makes more
things of that kind it reproduces things
of that metamorphosing kind anyway but
you can't say that I think because in
ferns there are two steps not one with
multiplication and just for good measure
both of them involve bottlenecks and
these two things occur before recurrence
and that makes it difficult to identify
a reproducing continuant in the system
there are plenty of continuance things
that persist any of those things could
be seen as continuance and plenty of
producing ones plenty of the objects
that produce something else but no
reproducing continuance at least in
their familiar sense so there's the
ferns and let's now move on and talk
about another case case with yet another
arrangement of these sorts of features
so this figure represents the life cycle
of a particular kind of jellyfish the
skipper's oh and jellyfish
this is a 19th century
illustration by matthias schleiden
these are the familiar kinds of
jellyfish the most familiar kind so in
this kind of jellyfish there is an
alternation as there is in the ferns now
adults are alternation between a polyp
and a Medusa form where the Medusa is
the swimming form the familiar
bell-shaped jellyfish form and the polyp
which is formed by development of a
sexually produced larva so that Medusa's
sexually reproduce well
the pursuit the Medusa's sexually
produce that what they produce is not a
Medusa but a polyp or rather a larva
that grows up to a polyp where the polyp
does not swim around like a jellyfish
but lives attached to a surface on the
sea bottom and then you have a process
by which polyps give rise to juvenile
Medusa's which grow up and then and then
sexually reproduce so there we have in
the schleiden diagram a 14 step picture
of the skipper's Island jellyfish
lifecycle here's a drawing of the
essential features using the drawing
conventions that I introduced earlier so
in some ways it's like the fern in some
ways it's different before recurrence
before you get back to where you started
there are now well as in the fern there
are two multiplication events only one
bottleneck unlike the fern case and
there are sexes at the multiplication
step that includes the bottleneck
so as the sliding diagram I think nicely
emphasizes in the drawing you have a
step which a single polyp fragments not
into one so it does not metamorphose
into a single Medusa but but well
producers is the general word to use
many Medusa it fragments into things
that give rise to more than one Medusa
so you have a multiplicative step at
step 11 here which does not involve a
bottleneck because there's no dramatic
narrowing and structure to a single
cells to
or something like it at that stage as
there was in the firm in their second
multiplicative event okay so two
multiplication steps one bottleneck and
sex at the multiplication step that also
has the bottleneck that's one kind of
jellyfish in Cuba's Island jellyfish in
contrast which Australians are all
familiar with as including the
absolutely terrifying box jellyfish the
sea wasp in Cuba's Island jellyfish in
contrast each polyp metamorphoses into a
single Medusa so you don't have the
step-in slide where a polyp gives rise
to many Medusa you only get one Medusa
but instead polyps themselves can
multiply by budding so again in that
case you have to multiplication steps
with one bottleneck and sex at one event
before recurrence okay so if now in the
diagrams I've given you three different
ways of rearranging the features the
human case the fern case and the
jellyfish case and of course many other
ways other ancient news features can now
be seen to be possible some of them as
far as I know are hypothetical
although giving a talk to an audience
like this I'm rare I'm reluctant to
suggest that something is merely
hypothetical there's probably in
someone's lab someone doing exactly
whatever I say anyway suppose you have
one bottle next step and one
multiplication step present before
recurrence as in the human case but
where they aren't the same step so in
humans is one multiplicative step and
one bottleneck but they are together you
might have them as separate steps in
which case two features of the familiar
reproductive events would appear and
appear once in the cycle but at
different places for me it's the
multiplication steps that are in some
sense the most important ones with
respect to identifying the beginning of
life of a new continuant now I think I
think that in part because of the
importance of multiplication in
Darwinian Pro
and others might think about things
differently
and I wouldn't want to argue about this
I don't see that as something one can
really argue about what I do want to
assert more strongly is the fact that it
is these dissociations of the things
that are together in a human life cycle
that depart from the structure that make
makes thinking in terms of reproducing
continuance natural and convenient when
we look at the living world incidentally
it used to be thought until quite
recently that there was at least one
case where a barnacle went through a
one-celled bottleneck stage without
multiplication now in most cases we have
a one-celled stage was at least the
potential for multiplication there was
thought to be a barnacle in which there
was a one-celled stage with no
multiplication it seemed that in these
barnacles which are which are parasites
of crabs the barnacle is able to cross
into the interior of the crabs body by
taking it down to a single celled stage
to get through the shell whereupon it
then grows up again into a multi-celled
organism so assuming that the normal
outcome would be a single multi-celled
stage inside each crab this would then
be a case where there are two bottleneck
stages in the life cycle one
multiplicative and one non
multiplicative and where the
multiplicative one involves sex I didn't
draw that one in part because the most
recent work has indicated unfortunately
for people like me that there is no
reduction to a single celled stage after
all more high-powered microscopic
techniques showed that that was that was
not so and that the invader remains
multicellular at every stage in its
passage through into the interior of the
crab so it's not as it once seemed to be
a case where there's two bottlenecks at
one of which is non multiplicative in a
lifecycle we could discuss more cases
but instead I think I'll now start
saying what
think this all means first the point of
the framework is to make clear and to
will Express the idea that the kind of
cyclical production seen in familiar
cases of reproduction like human
reproduction is a subset of a larger
collection of phenomena both actual and
possible so this once again the simplest
cases simple for us to think about not
simple in their biology have a cycle
where there's before recurrence there's
one multiplication step one bottleneck
and sex all at roughly the same place
now if those features are in care are in
place as in the humans a good deal of
metamorphosis can take place without
interfering with the intuitive
impression of there being reproducing
continuance as the units that are doing
all this stuff sometimes there's no sex
at the step that at the step with a
bottleneck and multiplication or lose no
sex at a step with a bottleneck and
multiplication and this has prompted
some people to recognize distributed
evolutionary individuals large
distributed objects they're in some
sense one thing that grow rather than
reproduce through a bottleneck stage
that's not the way I'm going here I'm
taking it that bottlenecks are a mark of
reproduction as we move further and
further from a situation like the human
case with a single multiplicative sexual
bottleneck we reach phenomena that are
harder and harder to think about in
terms of ordinary reproduction by a
continuant in a case like the jellyfish
with two multiplication steps there's
some disruption of the familiar pattern
in cases like the fern where there where
both multiplication steps have their own
bottleneck there's more disruption still
so I think of all this as showing a need
for us to take the idea of reproduction
differently in biology from the way it's
been taken so far
now of course in biology everybody knows
about complex life cycles none of this
is novel it's well known basic biology
but in discussions of evolution a simple
like makes like assumption a simple
heredity type assumption is often
embedded in descriptions of what's going
on well you might ask you know how is
that possible why aren't the
descriptions designed to deal with cases
like this I think part of it is at
normal and unobjectionable feature of
scientific language where you simplify
in some contexts because it would be too
awkward to say exactly what you think is
there and what you're saying is close
enough to being right as an
approximation and that's fine then when
you're doing specialized work use a
whole different vocabulary in which the
problem does not arise I think that's
very common in biology how would it go
in this case I think basically by
reducing things to the genetic level so
I think many biologists and I'll be
curious to hear if this is what people
actually do want to say I think many
biologists would say something like this
they would say look in Darwin's time it
was reasonable to proceed by talking
about evolution at the level of whole
organisms organisms live die reproduce
and when you do that they like makes
like assumption age Mackay's is an
important feature of a story but now we
can go lower and talk about evolution at
the level of genetic change and in all
those cases with ferns and jellyfish and
so on there is continuity and
persistence at the genetic level the
genes stay there through all this change
at the organism level and a person might
say that's what solves the problem
evolution just is change at the level of
genes and gene frequencies some genes do
better than others they change mutate by
mutation and so on they might do all
this by having very complicated effects
at the level of the whole organism
polyps and Medusa and sporophytes and
comida fights but it's not necessary to
track those objects very carefully or
rather it's not necessary to track those
objects
respect to their parent offspring
relations when you're describing
evolution in organisms like this because
the real reproductive action goes on at
the level of genes and we should note
indeed that Lewin turns three part
summary of evolution the one I gave
earlier can be applied to genes as
objects so genes vary genes reproduce or
replicate they're copied one might be
copied more than another and so on and
when they're copied they're copied very
accurately so there's heritability and
genes of course do not have alternation
of generations a makes a and then a
makes a again either does so well or
badly and I think that has been the
tacit treatment of complex life cycles
by evolutionists to quite a while I
think I suspect that would be an answer
that some people might want to give to
some of what I've been saying here so
what do I say in response to that here
is what I would say in response well one
possible response is well we now have
two frameworks where the two ways of
talking about these cases one of them
reduces to the level of genes and one
abstract and treats reproduction by
these larger things in terms of a
framework like the one I've sketched
here and they give different
perspectives on the same facts so what
I'm doing in a way in this talk is
rearranging or organizing in a
particular way some facts that are
usually handled somewhat differently and
the two frameworks can coexist well in
many ways I think that's okay I don't
have a big problem with that but I want
to push for a slightly more ambitious
treatment of the framework that I've
described the new framework is more
general and in particular what DNA does
is another special case a variety that's
handled within the framework so let's
now look at how the replication of DNA
or what's often referred to just as the
persistence of genes let's look at how
that appears in a framework like this
well it's a very tight cycle a very
tight form
cyclical production and a very high
fidelity one where a makes a with very
little error where when I say a here I
mean just a short double-stranded
segment of DNA so a makes a that a makes
a again now this is an unusual sort of
thing in biology in chemistry I take it
it's a rather unusual thing it's hard to
get using the machinery of basic
biochemistry and a 2a event in this
sense the same making the same what's
more common is cycles where a makes
rather a and B makes C and D and C + D
make en F and then e and F make a and B
against it's like making unlike with
cycles is more easy chemically than like
makes like now some forms of RNA are
seen as an important exception to this
and the RNA world hypothesis for the
origin of life is seen as important for
that reason so one way of thinking about
how things all begin is by thinking well
despite the fact that it's a bit
chemically unusual there is a self
reproducing chemical at the beginning of
the whole process another way of
thinking about things including a way of
thinking about how things might have all
begun is different it's to say that the
unusual eight a cycle in DNA the tight
self reproducing cycle is something that
cells found a way to do to achieve in
order to make possible the unusual
function that DNA serves with him selves
so in cells now DNA functions roughly
speaking is a kind of memory molecule as
a repository of information about the
sequences of the protein molecules that
do most of the actual work in cells now
DNA is not just a memory it's also part
of the control machinery so I think of
it as something that was probably
originally memory but on which a control
think function has also grown especially
by the evolution of genes that make
products that themselves function to
affect the transcription of other genes
more importantly the tight a to a cycle
is not something that DNA itself somehow
does it's achieved by other machinery
within the cell it's achieved by enzymes
in particular roughly half a dozen main
enzymes and some minor players as well
and those enzymes the ones that make it
possible for DNA to copy they require a
lot more cellular machinery to make
those so I'm trying to put DNA as just
one of the cases within this framework
and a rather unusual case brought into
being by a lot of chemical invention on
the part of cells so the unusual
phenomena involving DNA here and don't
provide an alternative to the whole
story but they are one of the cases the
story covers another very different kind
of case which I'll cover very quickly
because when I hit on this ninja to the
very end is seen in cultural phenomena
cultural transmission and I would like
to apply a phenomenon a framework like
this to cultural cases now at the moment
some of the phenomena some of the
features I've used in this talk like
bottlenecks in particular perhaps aren't
really that applicable to cultural
transmission the transmission of ideas
and so on but let me suggest you towards
a generalization of the framework so in
cultural contexts ideas recur behaviors
recur artifacts recur we make more
computers more cars and so on in a way
influenced by what happened with the
previous one so you have you have change
of production that includes cycles here
as well let's talk about a simple case
where you have an idea that leads
someone to sing a tune which other
people hear so the cloud here is a sort
of thought bubble the thought leader
gives rise to an audible tune which in
turn is heard by somebody gives rise to
a new internal state a thought in that
person which leads them to reproduce the
tune and so on so in ordinary cultural
cases you have sight you have recurrence
you have production with cycles and you
appear to have an alternation in
something like the case scene in the
ferns now when people write about this
in the literature on cultural evolution
what people tend to do is downplay the
alternation the fern like character of
this by treating the thoughts or the
ideas or the intellectual things as an
innocent primary and treating the
audible manifestations of the thoughts
as sort of mere phenotype their
secondary is not as fundamental to the
analysis as the as the informational
side of things but there are problems
with this in particular there's a
problem that's highlighted by
comparisons with the fern and jellyfish
and so on cases I've been describing in
the biological cases one other thing
that is disruptive to simple views of
self production and reproduction is the
presence of sex and I take it to be a
feature of cultural cases that unlike
all the biological cases that I've
talked about so far you can have sex
more than once before recurrence so in
the humans the ferns and the jellyfish
sex at least only occurred once before
you got back to where you started in the
cycle in cultural cases I take it sex
can be far more ubiquitous more than one
idea might give might share their
responsibility for a particular audible
tune and more than one audible tune
might share responsibility for a new
idea forming in someone's head so in the
cultural cases there are particularly
strong ways in which impediments to a
reanalysis of the case that tries to
downplay genuine alternation are present
that's all I'll say about the cultural
cases and it gestures towards the kind
of generality that I want to that I hope
for here now in many scientific contexts
generality is not particularly important
scientists spend lots of their time
working on particular pieces of a larger
system
sometimes it is in scientific context
especially in theoretical discuss in
discussion in philosophy as I see it
generality is pretty much always
important it's a large part of what
defines what philosophy is it's a
central part of the enterprise so you
might have a situation in which a
framework like the one sketched here
which applies a single apparatus to
firms jellyfish ideas and culture genes
themselves and so on has more importance
in a philosophical description than a
than a scientific one perhaps that's
true in any case though what I want to
emphasize is that I don't see the
genetic reductionist option here and my
treatment of cyclical production as
aimed at the same phenomena and
complementary rather the new framework
is supposed to be broader and it's
supposed to treat the particular tight
cycles visible in genic replication as
an unusual as one unusual case ok how
are we doing I've got just two minutes
or so yeah I think I'll just hit my very
last point I just to bring the thing to
its intended clothes so individuality of
the familiar horse and man type is a
derived trait especially in large
systems like ourselves the evolution of
individuals like ourselves of this kind
involves the organization of biological
material both in space and in time now
here I've looked specifically at
organization in time at life cycles that
make it natural to connect ignite
continuing and reproducing individuals
and life cycles that don't so why don't
we ask as a final question is there some
generalizations that might be made about
what evolutionary factors there are that
tend to give rise to life cycles that
support thinking in terms in familiar in
terms of familiar notions of
individuality well a discussion like
that is complicated and difficult for
many reasons one REE
is the fact that we're talking here
about the evolution of the machinery
that makes evolution itself occur so for
example bottlenecks have important
evolutionary consequences they may make
lineages more likely to generate novelty
but that's probably not why bottlenecks
exist still with those all sorts of
cautions in place that means that I
offer a few closing thoughts on this
topic
the idea of division of labor is usually
a PI applied to spatial parts of the
northern is amaura system but it can
also be applied to stages including
metamorphosing stages and alternation of
generations over space division of labor
is a form of heterogeneity or difference
that does not compromise collective
individuality your one thing in a sense
even though your parts play different
roles within the whole and the same
thinking I think can be applied to time
familiar cases of metamorphosis to start
with often have a division of labor for
example between feeding and reproductive
stages and also other tasks such as
dispersal a temporal division of labor
is associated with special expenses
compared to a spatial division of labor
though a temporal division of labor is
associated with expenses of breakdown
and rebuilding and sometimes a
temporarily organized division of labor
can be replaced by a spatially organized
one here I think it's important as many
people have noted that complex life
cycles are often associated with simpler
which means here spatially simpler
organisms and simplification of a life
cycle is seen in some very conspicuous
lineages such as flowering plants and
vertebrates like ourselves
so one evolutionary path has been a path
that goes towards a large
physiologically complex life form like
you and I but has a simpler life cycle
than very various of its relatives and
likely ancestors and then I think is
part of what gives rise to the paradigm
folk biological easily recognized
organisms Aristotle's individual man and
Aristotle's individual horse which are
the sorts of objects I suspect also back
before Aristotle that most induced us
when we began to talk and think to talk
and think in terms of subject predicate
structure a structure that has exerted
such enormous effects on the
philosophical tradition
with respect to
testify
yes more something that exacerbates the
problem than is something that gestures
towards a particular solution so suppose
I agree with you which I do and think
that right if if at both stages we can
talk about the traits that are
associated with fitness then surely that
constrains what we say about
reproduction well what do we say about
each stage we in Fitness is usually
understood in terms of differential
reproductive output and here all we have
to say as well as the differential
productive output but because
sporophytes are not making sporophytes
the currency of fitness is not a thing
of the same sort as the parent it's not
differential reproduction but just
differential production and I think once
we say that I see that as pushing us
towards this kind of generalization
where rather than treating reproduction
is a kind of fundamental universally
applicable part of the theory we now
have to say well there's this forms of
production that involve making the same
and those forms of production that
involve making different and that's just
how we're going to have to think in the
light of these cases so I agree very
much with your with your saying look an
important sort of indicator here is the
fact that Fitness talk is applicable
both times I agree with that and see
these as exacerbating the problem with
the usual way of talking
the story of Jesus coming back
as a result
as driving all these stages is a
beautiful story
how does how does thinking about these
different terms
give me any more insight into what's
taking place in the role of spoil a [ __ ]
that's odd of baby productions it's such
a it's a beautiful story I don't know I
don't have a view once how specifically
it would be best applied to yeast and I
don't know nearly enough about yeast I
think - is this this is a non
multiplicative step in my terms am i
right in saying that right so the the
sport sporulation itself is not a
multiplicative event
so once you've only once it's non
multiplicative I think of as
metamorphosis so here we have a story
about an important kind of metamorphosis
and the yeast itself if it only has a
single multiplicative event before you
get back to where you started from it's
just like people that's just a situation
where this change within the lifespan of
a persisting thing I think
yeah two people case yeast just like us
because you only have one if I'm right
I'm here grasping the bits of
non-existent yeast biology in my brain
but I only one multiplicative event
before recurrence of the form you
started with then it's just like it's
just like people
the key thing to try to understand was
why did new forms of organization come
about but I might you describe is the
abstract elements of a system that could
be combined in different ways and that
poses them the question of how you
transition I've given you everything I
have this this this is this is pretty
much brand new and I am thinking about
this but I don't have anything developed
beyond I'm hoping what I would like to
think about it this framework is that it
organizes a whole bunch of things that
are not usually seen as similar to each
other and identifies relevant
relationships within which questions
about likely transitions can be can be
phrased so the very end of a talk I said
if you want to know why there are things
like Aristotle's horse and man a
transition between a temporally
organized and a spatially organized
division of labor might be might be a
part of it
now I chose to mention that because
perhaps the idea is familiar but I
hadn't seen it in Leo's book or the man
Smith and death variable because I offer
that as one there's one small piece I
would I would hope that there will be
other pieces of a similar nature